so we saw that a conservative forces
path independent and we also have
examples of forces which are path
dependent if you have path two and path
one and the work done is path dependent
so that means for each path we would get
a different answer then we call this
force F we denote it by NC is called non
conservative and again we see that
friction is the best example of a non
conservative force and if we go again
for a non conservative work if we
integrate from the initial point to the
final point for instance on our path one
of this non conservative force so if we
integrate this way and if we reverse the
interval and so we go back from the
final point to the initial point on path
to that these integrals will not be
equal to the negative of each other
because the quantities are different for
the different paths in general and so
this is nonzero and in fact that's the
property of non conservative forces that
the work done around a closed path for a
non conservative force is not equal to
zero in general there may be one
specific closed path in which that
answer is zero but in general it's non
zero